hey aqua
all right we're gonna wait for a few
more people to raise their hands then we
can go ahead and get started
um i'm gonna get started with uh
farbot hey quite the last two games
lou is really picked up as defensive
intensity what have you seen from him
that he's been able to step it up as
well as he has
just knowing what coverage she's in and
you know um
we're big on him trying to box those
guys out uh you know he's doing a great
job at it
he did well tonight um i said just being
locked in
and um you know using his um hands
trying to get deflections i mean you
know it's been big for us
okay let's move over to miriam
hi kawhi congrats man um so
you guys are on the verge of making some
franchise hipstery and one game away
um from getting into the conference
finals for the first time um
does that mean anything to you guys i
mean
it's it's always good if uh you if you
could
if you can't make it to the next round
but uh you know we got a lot of work to
do still
um the denver team does not quit um you
know
they are good uh they got a good group
over there a good coach
so uh we we still fighting
okay let's move over to uh shane young
hey kawaii all season doc has seemed to
harp on
limiting turnovers i think tonight only
one player had
multiple turnovers is is that when you
feel like you're at your best whenever
you are controlling the pace and keeping
uh control the ball
yeah i think you know any team if uh
in a playoff game you have be there
under you know eight or
seven turnovers i think
any team is at their best when they do
that you know it's big to get a shot up
every time
down the far on offense and you know uh
you know you don't want to give you know
no easy offense but
with guys stealing a ball are you
throwing a bad pass and they get laid up
on it
let's move over to cameron
hey kawhi congratulations on the win i
want to ask about the intensity that you
guys came out with
tonight to kind of really jump on them
defensively versus the past couple of
games
where you got it took a minute for you
guys to get into that defensive flow
what was different tonight and what was
different in the mindset and mentality
coming into the game that has been
different in the other nights
i'm just trying to focus on it i guess
um
you know it finally carried over to
tonight's game
uh i think you know we still got to
tighten some things up they missed some
easy shots
early on as well and uh you know we just
got to get better
okay let's move over to tamir
why uh another impressive uh defensive
game for you guys
uh just can you speak to where you think
the team is
again i'm just uh coming together on
both ends of the floor
it looks like you guys have really
started to communicate a lot better as
the playoffs have gone on but
where do you think you guys are um you
know we're all still laying each other's
just you know a different team um
you know especially with me and pg and
uh even the guys that been here it's a
bit different style of play
different voices that you're hearing so
we're still trying to come together
you know i don't know where we are i
know that we just want to keep getting
better
and that's the focus on each and every
day is just being a better unit
we have time for one more uh we'll move
over to
uh um
hey kawaii i was wondering what uh what
you saw from trez tonight does he look
like
he's starting to get his rhythm back
uh you know tonight
he jumped into the ball uh early um
you know showed hands very aggressive on
the defensive end
um which led to some offensive uh you
know baskets for him
getting his energy up into the pain
knocking down some big free throws for
us
um you know he did well now he was
talking on the floor as well
and uh running into the screen so it was
a big part
we need everybody to you know win these
games
all right thanks kawaii
how's it going paul uh
yeah where are you ordering all right
getting the food out already okay let's
go ahead get started uh
let's get started with uh claudia
all right congratulations first of all
the score doesn't show it but the
nuggets played hard and you had to take
timeouts to slow you know their momentum
what is the biggest challenge with
denver
i um just that player movement um this
team been together for a while now
um so they they're continuity offense
uh where they know each other they they
cut they move around
um i think that's with biggest um
thing about denver is the player
movement
everyone go inside orlando we're gonna
go to uh kyle
um do you you guys were able to come
back from
their rally in the second half do you
feel like this series has given you
a better understanding of how this team
needs to
up its intensity and sort of keep that
going throughout the whole game
uh yeah i thought today um
was was great uh from that standpoint
uh we started off the game defensively
um
which we struggled to do um in this
series
um first quarter was amazing defensively
um
yeah i mean they made their runs again i
keep saying the game is always gonna be
a run so i think
in that third quarter i thought we
brought the defense back um
even when they made their runs um in the
fourth quarter i thought we rallied
again
and got stopped when we needed uh to put
the game away so
um i think we're finding and figuring
out um
you know once our defense is there that
creates everything for
for this team especially for our offense
stay in orlando and move to uh danger
um i mean i got experience
guarding point guards um
dating back to my rookie year garden
derrick rose so
um you know it's a different matchup but
i'm comfortable guarding smaller guys so
it's just keeping them in front but
using my length to bother them um
you know mixing it up trying to keep a
body on them
um just pressure
that's it okay we're gonna move over to
andrew that in the bubble
no on the link uh paul apologies if this
was just asked a little bit a version of
it couldn't quite hear but
as hot as jamal was in that first series
um when you guys watched that entering
this round
were there advantages you saw for how to
defend him because he has not shot well
the entire series
um well i thought in that utah series
i thought they just did a great job of
with their player movement
um with this team we got so many
defenders um
so many guys that like to defend um
we've been taking that challenge just to
pressure him up
stay on his body um
and and just take them out the game
but i mean you saw the first first uh
series was a big emotional series for
denver um
so they they were going to have some
legs and some
fatigue uh from that first series
um so we just you know we knew that
coming into this series that
we can't give them no life um you know
the
team like that you can't give them no
life okay we're gonna move over to nikki
k
hey paul congratulations everyone knows
uh lou williams
is a walking bucket but what can you say
about his efforts on the defensive end
this series and
how have you seen him grow throughout
the postseason with what he's doing on
defense
uh i think for lewis you know he just
tries
um you know everybody knows he's not a
defensive player but he tries
and i mean that's all you can ask for um
out of luke just tried uh you know nine
times out of ten
uh he's making some big plays um you
know
so it's it's for louis it's great it's
great that he's
in rotations um you know
he's pinning down and helping the bigs
um he's being crafty with his hands
uh you know i think just his effort has
just been amazing
okay we're going to move over to cameron
hey paul congratulations on the win
tonight i want to ask you i got a kind
of a two-part question
about the sense of urgency you guys came
out with
what was different from the past games
two and three that you didn't really
have come out with that same
urgency that you guys showed tonight and
then about your team
uh continuity kind of how you feel that
you guys are coming together as a unit
how do you feel about that kind of new
annuity um i think just at some point we
got to string some wins together
instead of you know winning losing
winning losing i mean we
at some point we got to start shrinking
some together and
uh i thought you know that was the
mindset tonight
um string some games together
let's let's take the approach to put
these games away early
and come out aggressive and uh we did
that tonight i think our continuity is
growing
i think this team is getting more and
more comfortable together um
you know i think the challenge is is
allowing us
uh to come together um and we've been
accepting these challenges
uh we're having fun with it and we're
growing at the same time it
for you tonight brother appreciate it
all right thanks